a grand summation of the human condition
which is that we are fundamentally
suspended in paradox i was reading a
book called maps of the mind where
different philosophers and psychologists
kind of present their case for making
sense of the human condition the human
paradox suspended between mortality and
divinity simultaneously gods and worms
and so what was articulated is that to
be human is to be suspended in paradox
and the problem is that our ignorance
comes from living in a black and white
world our ignorance comes from living in
a world of
yes no living in a world of polarity
living in a world where we are
confounded by the impossibility of being
both mortal and divine and yet
living in a world in which we pay no
attention to the fact that we live in
paradox is to be asleep
it's not to be awake you know the
western material world view while great
at mapping
the physical contours of reality
it leaves no room for interiority and
paradox and so until to live in a world
of
thesis and antithesis at war with each
other
contradictions right paradox confusion
anxiety agitation a world of thesis and
antithesis leads to war conflict
but a world that embraces paradox that
embraces synchronicity that embraces
that we don't know what we don't know is
a world in which thesis and antithesis
seemingly irreconcilable are resolved by
synthesis which is a higher level order
understanding a higher dimension that
makes room for paradox a rational world
in which irrational forces exist a
rational world in which mystery is real
you know like like like a venn diagram
seeming opposites are reconciled by a
higher level understanding thesis and
antithesis are resolved by synthesis in
this case
structure and chaos oh structure too
much oh chaos too much oh no but guess
what balance you know or like discipline
discipline or no surrender surrender
forever at war oh no flow
resolves that paradox higher level
understanding a place where discipline
and surrender meat thesis and antithesis
converge are reconciled by synthesis
higher level understanding and that is
the human condition so seemingly the
paradox of living in paradox of being
suspended in paradox and somehow being
unable to hold that all at once how can
i be both mortal finite and also a god
how can i be suspended in paradox how
can i live in a world in which
i am food for worms but also divine
light a world in which i am music and
dance seemingly sprouting into existence
in every moment and that
that idea
is given
idea is
is surrendered too
is is is finally
resolved reconciled in artistic
expression
i think art is where our divinity and
our mortalities manifest god's on stage
gods and worms god's with anuses but
gods nonetheless
blood sweat and tears on stage showing
what is divine within us like characters
on screen beings made of light that are
also aging and dying we are suspended in
paradox but we resolve that paradox
through art
art is where our divinity and our
mortality meet creativity is where our
divinity and our mortality meet
synchronicity is where our divinity and
our mortality meet when the objective
world and the narrative world touch
as jordan peterson said and i know that
is real because i've experienced it the
felt reality of direct experience or
what the greeks call catalepsis a truth
from which nothing can dislodge you
a truth from which nothing can dislodge
you to know this i think is to know god
to know this is to know awe
in quaking annihilating glory to know
this is to know the birth of stars and
the birth of gods to know this is
everything
you know to know this is everything and
and and i think that's how that's the
place that where i arrive in all of my
wrestling finally and leaping into the
abyss and realizing that it's a feather
bed it's believing that the paradox can
be resolved that's suspended
between our mortality and our divinity
is
is us
our humanity
so that's that's what i wanted to share
thanks for listening guys you guys are
yeah okay good thank you thank you okay
thank you
sorry i just was feeling it i was
feeling it
that's that's like yeah yeah
cool cool yeah